lo que queremos pensar en este vídeo es
cuáles de estos valores a b c d y e son
aquellos que para esta gráfica roja que
de hecho es la gráfica de no sería igual
a fx entonces cuáles de estos valores x
alcanzan máximos o mínimos relativos de
esta función f de x muy bien y te invito
a que hagas una pausa y que pienses
cuáles de estos son máximos relativos y
cuáles son mínimos relativos
entonces para poder empezar a
clasificarlos vayamos primero con a muy
bien entonces si queremos ver aquí aquí
ya se ve que está como en una colina
entonces lo más intuitivo y de hecho es
como la idea clásica de lo que es un
máximo relativo es justamente que
podemos dar aquí un intervalo por
ejemplo este de tal suerte que todos los
que estén dentro de ese intervalo
estarán por debajo de la función
evaluada en a entonces de hecho por aquí
anda
efe
verdad hay que andar y todos estos
puntos que se encuentran en este
intervalo verde que acabo de marcar en
realidad están evaluadas bajo la función
por debajo de f así que podemos
garantizar que aquí hay un máximo
relativo muy bien y voy a abreviar lo
para hacer mucho más breve ahora
pensemos qué pasa en b pensemos qué pasa
en vez digamos que damos un intervalo
aquí en b
muy bien entonces digamos este es un
ejemplo digamos un prototipo de qué es
lo que está pasando pero en realidad no
perdemos mucha generalidad de hecho
sabemos que efe db anda como por aquí
más o menos y aunque parezca
contraintuitivo éste en realidad es un
máximo relativo en principio y en
realidad es suceda justo porque es
discontinua nuestra función verdad por
ejemplo aquí si si damos este intervalo
todos los valores estarán en este en
este digamos en estas en estos segmentos
de curva o en estos pedacitos de curva y
si te das cuenta el valor
efe db se encuentra por arriba de éstos
entonces este digamos b alcanza un
máximo relativo también muy bien esto
fue un poquito contraintuitivo pero no
pasa nada vamos a ver qué pasa ahora con
c vamos a dar otra vez un intervalo
no sé este intervalo y veamos cómo es la
función otra vez aquí tenemos un brinco
pero no no no pasa nada veamos ya que
dimos este intervalo podemos ver que del
lado izquierdo está muy por arriba del
valor
fcc verdad aquí está fdc muy bien y que
pasa del lado derecho pues también va
subiendo de hecho está más arriba del
valor fdc así que podemos garantizar que
se tiene un mínimo relativo
un mínimo relativo en fcc muy bien ahora
bien qué pasa con d nuevamente des debe
ser claro que es un máximo relativo
verdad damos otro intervalo alrededor de
d y vemos que todos estos valores que
todos estos valores están muy por debajo
de f porque f desde ahora anda hasta acá
arriba aquí está
fd y finalmente es un mínimo relativo y
de hecho ese es como la idea prototipo
si la idea prototipo de lo que es este
un mínimo relativo entonces espero que
te haya servido para tener mucha más
idea de cómo encontrar mínimos y máximos
relativos